suiza le dice sí al pase sanitario y se
convierte en el primer país que aprueba
en las urnas este documento que indica
que una persona se ha vacunado o se ha
recuperado del cobi 19 los primeros
resultados mostraron que alrededor de
dos tercios de los ciudadanos apoyaron
la ley en toda la nación alpina
las vacunas siguen siendo la herramienta
más poderosa que tenemos contra este
virus diga lo que diga la gente
cualquier nueva variante que surja
entonces entiendo que una medida como el
pase de vacunación es puesto en marcha y
solicitado por nuestras autoridades
detroit sin embargo suiza al igual que
gran parte de europa ha presenciado
manifestaciones violentas en relación a
las medidas sanitarias la policía cercó
la sede del gobierno y el parlamento en
berna la capital para garantizar la
seguridad de varios políticos e
insultados por algunos ciudadanos e
incluso amenazados de muerte algo
atípico en este país algunos opositores
incluso consideran la medida
antidemocrática por supuesto el punto
realmente molesto de esta ley es que
ignora una serie de derechos
constitucionales en particular el
artículo 10 sobre las libertades
personales con este certificado de cubit
que de hecho es una obligación de
vacunación es así que esto es
extremadamente impactante en un país
como suiza que no tiene tales
obligaciones
el referéndum se produjo en respuesta a
la llegada de la variante omicron a
europa que está clasificada como una de
preocupación por la o ms y en un momento
en que el número de contagios en suiza
son más de siete veces mayor que a
mediados de octubre